how realistic do you think it is though
that companies are going to want to
invest in a country which is currently
being invaded by another
first of all thank you very much indeed
and I want to thank United Kingdom your
government your Parliament your people
for providing such an important events
today with the recovery conference and
with that situation we have now a two
front
and the battlefield where Ukrainian
fighting not only for our soil but
fighting protecting Global Freedom
Global democracy and this is the not
assisting Ukraine this is just investing
in your own Security in your own in
protecting your own democracy second
front is a front for protecting
democracy inside the country for
creating unique investment climate for
promoting reform and it is very
important that package of United Kingdom
for 3 billion for the long guarantee
from the World Bank 50 billion Euro
which declared today Ursula of
underlying from European Community
United States investment everything of
that is for promoting protecting and
pushing reform creating a unique
investment climate and with that
situation I am absolutely confident that
Ukraine has an absolutely unique
investment opportunity and we are not
talking about just a recovery we're
talking about building up a new country
the most richest soil on the continent
the unique training of the people the
unique opportunity with the energy
system and many many others and I know
that and today in London we have a very
good discussion with the private sector
about their Readiness to provide the
investment in Ukraine for that we need
to provide all necessary thing for
democracy rule of law anti-corruption
infrastructure protecting democracy
freedom of press freedom of people and
we are now United to build up new
Ukraine United to provide this reform
and the confidence for that play a
unique role you're obviously very
positive about the prospects for Ukraine
and the war but when you think of a time
frame what in your head do you think
it's the realistic time that Ukraine
will be free
excuse me please no schedule no time
everything depends now from the ability
of Ukrainian armed forces and I think we
have more than enough motivation we
surprised the world we do the miracle
and we stop the second biggest nuclear
power in the world and the second this
is the supply of the of our partners and
I am proud that I built up the new
Ukrainian Armed Forces since UCL 2014
when I was the president and that was
built on the standard of NATO
but there is not existing standard of
NATO and offensive troops of Ukraine do
not have a air dominance do not have a
jet fight do not have a most modern air
defense do not have a most modern red
electronic warfare system which Russia
Russia has two three five times more and
even during that situation we
demonstrate the progress during this
counter-offensive operation despite of
the fact that this is just a
reconnaissance by fire and this just
only 30 percent of our Brigade which was
reserved for the counter-offensive
operation is already involved in the
process we now finding out the place
where the attack of Ukrainian troops
would be the most efficient and we do it
quite successfully but Russia is very
strong Russian troops has a unique 15
months combat experience and now this is
a different troops than we have in the
2014 or at the 21st February 2022 we pay
for that more price but we do not have
any doubts about our Victory and the
sooner we receive jet fighter the sooner
we receive our defense the sooner we
receive high accuracy uh ammunition the
sooner would be our Victory our joint
Victory and that would be the victory of
democracy on the autocracy on the
dictatorship on the military criminal
and Ukraine now suffering from that
suffering from genocide suffering from
echocyte and the it is extremely
important to have the your shoulder
together with us in Ukraine